seinfeld might be one of the funniest
shows in tv history but showrunner larry
david had some truly dark rules about
its storylines keep watching to learn
more about david's bleak rulings
seinfeld was famously a show about
nothing jerry george elaine and kramer
would get into all kinds of awkward
predicaments which is typical for
sitcoms however in most other
programming the characters learn some
sort of lesson about morality and or
ethics they grow into better people by
the end of the episode even if they
completely forget said lesson by the
next one but not seinfeld the characters
would be precisely the same by each
episode's end it turns out there's a
good reason why because show creator
larry david had two very strict rules
about seinfeld no hugging and no
learning you can see this ethos in every
half hour installment there aren't any
sentimental moments where the friends
come together to hug one another after a
misunderstanding and they never learn
their lessons often going through a
comedy of errors just to wind up the
same exact people at episode's end as
the infamous series finale showed their
inability to become better people is the
whole point david once elaborated on
this to an interviewer saying a lot of
people don't understand that seinfeld is
a dark show if you examine the premises
terrible things happen to people they
lose jobs somebody breaks up with a
stroke victim somebody's told they need
a nose job that's my sensibility at
their core the four friends are awful
people as exhibited in season five's the
hamptons when jerry and elaine meet a
friend's new baby they proceed to call
it the ugliest baby that either one of
them has ever seen oh a little too much
chlorine in that gene pool and that's
them actually being nice on multiple
occasions they actually killed someone
by accident look at the insanely dark
season 8 episode the czechs in the
episode jerry hits elaine's boyfriend in
the head with an axe and he dies during
the subsequent surgery when the surgeon
gets distracted amazingly no one learns
a lesson of any kind instead the death
is just played for dark laughs but
nowhere is the show's insistence on
everyone being awful more evident than
in the episode the invitations in which
george's fiance susan dies usually when
a major character on a sitcom dies it's
a very special episode played straight
with some kind of emotional message but
not on seinfeld when susan died it was
done in a classic seinfeld-esque way she
was poisoned by licking cheap envelopes
because george was too stingy to pay for
nicer wedding invitations and george
isn't at all upset by her death in fact
he's not so secretly happy about it
because he had been trying to figure out
a way to break it off without looking
like the bad guy with her death not only
does he get out of the marriage but he
gets sympathy to boot he couldn't be
more pleased he's dead
yes
the reason she was killed off sounds
like it could have come out of a
seinfeld episode itself as jason
alexander later revealed that actress
heidi swedberg was fired from the show
because he couldn't figure out her sense
of humor
he told howard stern her instincts for
doing a scene where the comedy was and
mine were always misfiring and she would
do something and i would go okay i see
what she's going to do i'm going to
adjust her and then i'd adjust and she'd
change which brings us back to that
series finale where the four characters
go to jail when instead of helping a
robbery victim they merely watch and
laugh it was larry david's way of
telling the devoted audience that we
really shouldn't have been laughing at
this stuff all these years because these
are fundamentally bad people we're
identifying with the success of the show
ultimately inspired a whole sub-genre of
popular sitcoms like it's always sunny
in philadelphia and you're the worst
about bad people doing bad things of
course one of those is curve your
enthusiasm larry david's hbo show that
could be considered a spiritual
successor to seinfeld in a lot of ways
nevertheless we keep cheering these
awful protagonists on so it seems that
like the seinfeld characters themselves
we didn't learn anything either check
out one of our newest videos right here
plus even more looper videos about your
favorite shows are coming soon subscribe
to our youtube channel and hit the bell
so you don't miss a single one
[Music]